salve io mi chiamo fausto d'elia e
rappresento il team ex chiudo 3d ma
cos'è icub 3d potremmo definirla una
nuova espressione artistica che si pone
l'obiettivo di colpire positivamente
affascinare e stupire
e grazie a questa interazione che
abbiamo cercato di creare l'abbiamo
ideata progettata lavorata questa
interazione fra il la realtà virtuale
della video proiezione tridimensionale e
quella tangibile dei performer in scena
perché comunque noi cerchiamo attraverso
questo di accompagnarvi di coinvolgervi
in questo gioco di illusionismo virtuale
ovvio che dietro tutto questo c'è un
grande lavoro una grande sinergia tra i
performer lo staff tecnico
lunghe prove estenuanti
ovviamente bisogna calcolare il tutto
con precisione millimetrica
valutare le prove al millesimo di
secondo
per potervi proiettare in questa quarta
dimensione ed è grazie a loro ai ragazzi
che noi possiamo regalarvi questa
emozione ci auguriamo di avervi regalato
delle sensazioni dal forte impatto
emotivo perché questo è il nostro
obiettivo
viverlo insieme a voi momento per
momento pochi minuti pochi istanti che
richiedono un grande lavoro e per
completare il tutto abbiamo cercato di
inserire più espressioni artistiche o
sportive oggi in questa breve
presentazione che abbiamo portato qui
alte dx c'è solo una parte dello staff
con alcune espressioni fuse tra di loro
abbiamo per la ginnastica ritmica
giorgia marra
magia e illusionismo il nostro mago rudy
splendido ballerino di hip hop ma anche
coreografo co progettista di ciò che x3
di alessio verrone
in regia video tecnico grafico 3d nonché
co ideatore il 23 di fabio cascione
credetemi per noi è veramente un piacere
e un onore essere qui ad aprire questo
splendido appuntamento e vogliamo
ringraziare andrea pauli vogliamo
ringraziare tutto il pubblico presente
tutte le persone che hanno contribuito
per realizzare questo splendido
appuntamento grazie ancora a tutti
quanti da parte nostra